thank you thank you all very much
started I think this is a compelling
reason we why we need a much bigger
auditorium for the University as we move
forward thank you all very much for
coming it's a great pleasure for me to
welcome you to this Simon distinguished
lecture it's a particular pleasure to
welcome Sal Khan whose simple or
seemingly simple approach has had a
profound impact in the education of
millions and millions of people at
different stages including people like
Bill Gates who after whom this building
at least in part is partly named Sal
untold is started this approach
initially to teach mathematics to his
lease at a small scale and then when the
impact of the way it was being taught
was realized it was transformed to a
much larger audience we have I'm
particularly delighted that we've had an
opportunity to bring Sal here to talk to
a large campus community as part of the
Simon initiative he is here in
Pittsburgh to sit to receive the Hines
Awards tonight for which are given for
extraordinary achievements in different
spheres of life and of course he is
receiving it for his major contributions
to education through the Khan Academy
let me say a little bit about the Simon
lecture series of the Simon initiative
as you know last November in honor of
dr. Herbert Simon we launched the Simon
initiative to think about three things
at a time when technology is enabling
all of us especially those in the
education field to
empower individuals but at the same time
hundreds of millions of individuals to
learn different topics in a throughout
their lives it's very easy relatively
easy to ask the question what kind of
education can be delivered it's more
difficult to ask the question what has
been the impact of that education on
those who are receiving that education
through technology this is an area where
dr. Herbert Simon had a profound impact
not just on Carnegie Mellon but on the
global intellectual community and this
is why there was no doubt in anybody's
mind on campus that we should name this
initiative in honor of him this
initiative has three components to it
the first is to connect all parts of
campus dozens and dozens of faculty
hundreds of students researchers engaged
in this for several decades hopefully in
a seamless way so that we can coordinate
our internal activities and enhance the
impact of those activities which have
been substantial for the last several
decades
even to a to a new level secondly to
start a conversation at the national and
international level because this is an
area it's a relatively emerging area
with many many different wonderful
organizations approaching it from very
different points of view that's the
right thing to do but at least to
facilitate a conversation and a
collaboration among them including
organizations such as the Association of
American Universities and American
Association of public and land-grant
universities about the value of
technology in delivering education both
for on-campus and remote learning but at
the same time focusing on the the
outcomes from these learning that's the
second part of it as part of this we
launched something called the Global
Learning Council the third part is that
through decades of research at CMU we
probably have if not the largest data
bank or low
outcomes for an institution one of the
very largest data banks from decades of
research every keystroke that every
student has employed and that
information anonymously has provides a
rich fertile ground for research on
learning outcomes through the enormous
activities such as what Sarkar has done
how can we collectively work together
and take this to the next level this
data bank our goal is to make it
available openly to the world and invite
them to add to this data point so that
the global community benefits from this
those are the objectives of this so
received his undergraduate degree from
MIT we were just talking and our times
overlap even though we did not know each
other at that time not as students he's
a little younger than me by the way
right after just by a few years and a
little after that I'm surprised from
what he just told me he crossed the
river not only crossed that he had
crossed the cracks to the other side to
Harvard University received a master's
degree from MBA from Harvard Business
School and started working for a hedge
fund and while being a successful hedge
for an employee he realized that the
impact of this educational work could
probably be much more satisfying than
what he was doing and that led to this
enormous work that he has done over the
last four years so it's a great honor to
invite him and also to congratulate him
on the Hines Awards I would also like to
take this opportunity to thank the
heights and diamonds and the Heinz
Family Foundation for their enormous
support philanthropic support in so many
different domains
especially in Pennsylvania and in
Pittsburgh it's a great pleasure to have
with us also today is Andrei Heinz
who's in addition to his passion about
education he's also been a leader in
bringing his talents into environment
sustainability and design with the right
future planning in mind for the global
community and he lives in many different
continents and has as I've had the
pleasure of meeting him at least once
and having had the chance to talk to him
on several occasions it's a great
pressure to welcome him and also mrs.
Teresa Hinze has been a great supporter
and the Hines endowments and the Hines
awards are created in honor of the late
Senator Hines whose impact has been
profound nationally regionally and
internationally so with that
introduction let me invite Sal Khan to
come and give his Simon distinguished
lecture
so I always I always like to start these
conversations really just pulling the
audience
yeah I'm just curious I it looks like
there's a lot of students in the room
how many of you all actively use Khan
Academy in some way oh that's very good
and uh how many of y'all had use it when
you were in high school or okay okay and
how many of you have no idea what
khanacademy is usually there's a few
very good excellent talk to you
excellent
so so as as was introduced Khan Academy
has historically have been most known
for this collection of videos that I
started making for my cousin's really
almost almost about eight years ago now
well we'll see over the course of the
presentation that it's in our minds it's
much much more than than just the videos
it's interactive content exercises data
analytics tools for teachers things like
that but to get everyone on the same
page I will start with a montage of the
videos all these interactions are just
through the gravity this is an age right
after Isaac Newton I'll totally makes it
feel hot excellent question LeBron can
you determine which lightbulb is being
switched the things actually can
interbreed although for these two in
particular it seems like the mechanics
would get if this does not blow your
mind then you have no emotion not a
feeling oilers identity would be
appreciated at Carnegie Mellon but it's
much more than just the videos we have
an interactive computer science platform
the whole point of us doing this was to
really kind of highlight the the
creative side of computer science
students can work on stuff get feedback
from other students create portfolios of
their work we've actually used this for
in elementary schools we've also used
this in colleges we've had graduate
students use it we've actually hired two
people based on their portfolios that
they've created on the computer science
platform kind of the real meat of what
we've been doing is is our interactive
math experience where it's it's really
about students coming to the site taking
a pretest the system
understanding where they are building a
statistical model of what they know and
don't know and trying to give them
exercises with game mechanics to kind of
meet them where they are and and and and
let them learn at their own pace a
little snapshot of where we are now
we're used in almost every country three
hundred thousand educators are using us
in some way in their classroom we're
serving about 10 million monthly unique
users now and they've done nearly 2
billion exercises and and we'll talk a
little bit more about about what those
exercises are but before going into bed
and before going into where we are in
the future I will talk a little bit
about how this all happened and as was
introduced I think you'll have a kind of
a sketch of the story but I'll go to a
little bit more detail so you go you
rewind back to 2004 I had I was a year
out of Business School I was working as
an analyst at a small hedge fund I just
gotten married and I was born and raised
in New Orleans had family from New
Orleans visiting me in Boston and it was
my aunt uncle and their three kids the
oldest of which was my cousin Nadia 12
years old she had just finished sixth
grade and it just came out of
conversation that she was having trouble
with mathematics and it came out it was
you know unit conversion ounces to
gallons etc and so I I told Nadia I was
like look I I think you're fully capable
of this if you're willing to how about
when you go back to New Orleans we work
on the phone every day and she agreed
and so we started this was August of
2004 and the first month was kind of
difficult she'd completely convinced
herself that she's just not good at math
but then slowly she kind of things
started to click in she started to catch
up then frankly about two months into it
she became a little bit advanced and at
that point I became what I call a a
tiger cousin and I I called up her
school and I I said you know I really
think Nadia Rahman should retake that
placement exam they said who are you
all right I'm her cousin and somewhat
surprising that they allowed her to and
she went from a slow math track to an
advanced math track and has been on a
kind of a good trajectory ever since and
so I was intrigued was this a one-off
you know it was a fairly small
intervention on my part and so I started
working with her younger brothers and
then a couple of things happened over
the next two years the first is the firm
I was working for and it was literally
just myself my boss and his dog the you
he was the chief economist we we joked
when we actually have business cards the
we moved out to my boss's wife became a
professor at Stanford Law School so we
moved out to Northern California the
other thing that had happened was word
got around in the family that free
tutoring was going on so I found myself
every every day after work working with
ten fifteen cousin's family friends all
over the country I was using yahoo
instant messenger at the time had this
little doodle functionality so that we
could see each other's each other's
crawls and to help scale up you know my
background was was is in software and
you know I think anyone who's ever kind
of dabbled in software his always
anything you know there's got it I don't
know
Carnegie Mellon's done a lot of work
here anyone who's dabbling suffers this
seems like the ideal tool for for
somehow helping people learn things and
so I started to dabble I started seeing
my cousin's had gaps in needed practice
and things so I started creating these
little quiz generators in adding
fractions negative numbers exponents
very simple things giving them the steps
and then so that I could keep track of
what they're doing it put a little
database behind it and and and you know
I was kind of proud of this thing that
was happening and all my friends knew
about it and so in November of 2006 I
was at a dinner party and I was you know
at the end of the party most of people
had gone home and I was showing my
friends you know what I was working on
and the software in particular and one
of my friends is uli rums I should give
him full credit for this he said well
this is neat Sal but but how are you
scaling your actual tutorials with your
cousins and I said well you know it's
I'm actually not it's really difficult
now it's hard to do with even you know
five cousins on the same call that I
could I was do
with Nadia two years ago and he said
well you know I've got an idea why don't
you make some lessons as videos and
upload them onto YouTube for your
cousin's and I I said no no that that
that's that's a horrible idea
YouTube is for cats playing piano it is
not for serious mathematics but I I went
home for that weekend got over the idea
that it wasn't my idea and then I
decided to I decided to give it a shot
and you know those first those videos
were on the things that I saw my
cousin's kept asking me questions about
it it seems like or they were afraid to
ask questions about even more and so I
started I mean like twenty or thirty of
them and over the next month I just kept
telling my cousin's hey this is there
for your review let me know if you want
me if you want me to make more videos
and so after about a month I asked them
well what do y'all think about it and
they somewhat famously and back handedly
told me that you know that they like the
videos though they like me more on
youtube than in person and and and you
know I talked about that and I think
it's important to kind of think about
what they were saying and what they
weren't saying they they weren't saying
that they didn't appreciate me or that
they didn't appreciate having these the
access to me to ask questions to go deep
or even to request videos but what they
were saying when they when they said
that is that the first time you're
learning something or or even if it's if
something you learn three four years ago
but you're embarrassed that you forgot
it now it's hard to ask your cousin even
if you're if that person is trying not
to be judgmental you're embarrassed
you're in algebra but you forgot how to
divide decimals or you're the first time
you get exposed to the idea of
trigonometric functions it's it's hard
to keep pace with it with uh with the
instructor sometimes and so now you can
review it as many times as as you want
whenever you wanted to so taking that as
positive feedback I kept making more and
more of these videos and I just kept
working on the software but the videos
trying to have a life of their own
I obviously when you put it on YouTube
anyone can watch it and it soon became
clear that people who are not my
cousin's were watching and and you know
the comments started to come in and you
know there's a lot of them that first
were just being simple thank you and and
even that was a pretty big deal I don't
know how much time you
on YouTube most of the comments are not
thank you a little bit more edgy and and
but but then but then the comments got
got more intense and this is the reason
I was able to pass algebra class this is
the reason why I'm inspired to major in
engineering this is the reason why after
leaving the military that I I can
re-engage and go back and get my college
degree and I remember those early days
this was probably about two or three
years into making these videos probably
2007 I I got this one letter and I
immediately brought my wife forms like
this is incredible is just this this
this mother wrote saying both of her
sons have a learning disability that
that these videos were the only thing
that we're getting through to them and
and because of that her entire family
prayed for for me and my entire family
and and you could imagine that that was
that was pretty pretty intense stuff you
know I was an analyst at a hedge fund I
I wasn't used to people praying for me
at least and that way it was a good
hedge fund I joke about it it is and and
so so I just kept doing more and more
and more the the traffic kept growing
and growing and growing by 2008 I set
this up as a not-for-profit and even in
2008 I didn't fully think that this is
what what I was going to do you know
full time in the near future I thought
it was gonna be you know maybe we could
get some funding here and supported and
get volunteers on it but by 2009 the the
site it was about a hundred thousand
people were using it every month this
was all I was thinking about and so my
wife and I we sat down we looked at our
finances and you know we had some
savings kind of enough for a down
payment on a house in Silicon Valley but
it felt that that there's something here
what if I took the year off to try to
fully invest it hopefully someone would
appreciate the social return on
investment that this thing could create
and I think you know all entrepreneurial
stories whether it's a not-for-profit or
a for-profit they all kind of start with
that saying you you have to be a little
bit optimistic or a little bit
delusional even and and so I I took the
plunge and you know you
all right you meet with a lot of folks
you meet with a lot of foundations and
you get a lot of very polite well this
is really fascinating it's gonna be
awesome but it's not quite what we do
and that happened for several months and
you know you go into early 2010 I
started to get pretty nervous you know
my son had been born our expenses were
going off we were kind of digging into
you know that that down payment on the
house is no longer quite adequate for a
down payment on the house and so I
started getting really stressed about
you know and have I ruined my my
family's kind of financial future and I
was getting kind of paypal donations you
know five ten dollars here there if it
was any of you thank you but but but
then all of a sudden in May of 2010 a
$10,000 donation comes in so I
immediately see who it is her name is
Ann Doerr I immediately and choose based
in Palo Alto I email her back I said
thank you so much for your incredibly
generous donation this is the largest
donation that Khan Academy has ever
received if we were a physical school
you would now have a building named
after you which is quite an expensive I
think that's
and and and and and immediately rode
back she's like oh well you know I'm a
big fan I've used the site myself I've
used it with my daughter and so and I'd
love to have lunch to find out more more
of what what you want to do and so it
was the next week we met in downtown
Palo Alto at an Indian buffet restaurant
and Ann asks me so so what's your goal
here and I told it I've had these little
kind of little slide presentation III I
told her look you know when you fill out
the paperwork to be a not-for-profit the
IRS asks you your mission and I filled
out a free world-class education for
anyone anywhere and so Ann said well
that's that's ambitious how do you see
yourself doing that and I said well you
know it's it's a mission I don't think
you know I'm just going to achieve it
tomorrow and check it off and then move
on to healthcare or something but it's
but but but but but I think we can make
make a lot of progress and I showed her
kind of the software and I said you know
the videos obviously we're getting a
following but it's much more than just
videos it's about creating an
interactive platform it's about
connecting students giving them feedback
creating tools for teachers it's about
leveraging all the data and all the
analytics so that we can refine the tool
and also personalize instruction better
for students and so Ann said you know
this is this is pretty interesting it
looks like you're making a surprising
amount of headway I only have one
question how are you supporting yourself
and then as proud of a way as possible I
said I'm not and and and kind of nods
and I guess processes that and then and
then we part ways and then about there's
literally about 15 minutes later I'm
driving into my driveway in Mountain
View and and I get a text message from
Ann and it says you really need to be
supporting yourself I've just wired you
$100,000
so that was a good day and and then
frankly it was it was the beginning of a
crazier and crazier series of events a
month later I was uh I was running this
little summer camp for middle school
students and the whole idea is that you
know I'm this this virtual video-making
guy whatever it might be but I've never
imagined that that somehow the complete
education what I always imagined that
does is that liberates the classroom to
do more interesting things than just a
lecture and so I was running this little
summer camp with a friend where it was
all about you know having dialog and
running simulations and doing games and
working on projects and so I had a
little simulation running where I had
six seventh graders playing a game of
Risk and then I had the other twenty
seventh graders trading securities based
on the outcome of the game before his
good game and while that was happening I
start I start getting actually a series
of text messages for man which you could
imagine I now take very seriously and
they they read along they were actually
hard to read because it was you know
like it was unclear what order they came
in and it said along the lines I'm at
the Aspen ideas festival in the main
pavilion bill gates on stage last five
minutes talking about Kahn Academy so I
didn't know what to make of this so I
immediately boot the near seventh grader
off of a computer I started looking for
some evidence of this event that that
that Ann is referring to and in about 30
minutes I found the footage it was
literally a Walter Isaacson the head of
the Aspen Institute asks Bill Gates what
are you excited about and and bill I
called him Bill now
he just he just he just starts talking
about yeah there's this side I started
using with my kids that I also use
myself but they have all this nice stuff
about economics and finance and all of
that and you can imagine while I was
watching that all sorts of emotions
started to go through my head obviously
this was exciting this is like a it's
surreal it's like it's a it's like a
dream but then I actually started to get
a little nervous those videos were for
Nadia not big eights and and and then I
I went you know and so you could imagine
I went home that that afternoon and you
know some people had heard independently
some some actually some people had gone
to school with her actually in the
audience I told my wife and and and then
it was you know it was well what's the
next step what's the protocol here you
know do I call him I'm assuming he's not
listed and they they frankly left me in
that limbo for for about two weeks two
weeks later I all of a sudden I'm in my
walk-in closet about to record a video
and the cellphone rings I see it's a
Seattle number so hello hi this is Larry
Cohen on Bill Gates's chief of staff you
might have heard that Bill's a fan yeah
I heard that and we loved to fly up to
Seattle in if you're free in the near
future to find out more about what
you're doing and possibly ways that we
might help support you and and I was
looking at my my calendar for the month
completely blank I said yeah maybe next
Wednesday I've got to cut my nails do
some laundry
meet Bill Gates and Ryan at the same
time some folks from Google reached out
and by meeting meeting wand was kind of
similar to the meeting with an meeting
too was they said you know what would
you do with two million dollars and I
said is this an open question because
but when I I can't you know I obviously
told them the same things that I told
and I told the Gates Foundation and so
by fall of 2010 we had our first kind of
real initial support to become a real
organization for it to be really more
than just me operating out of a
operating out of a walk-in closet and so
what we started working on was
essentially the software part of Khan
Academy because that was always the the
real meat of the dream where the and and
so what do you see here is kind of a
zoomed out version of what we call our
knowledge map and I and I show this this
isn't our primary interface anymore but
it gives a good sense of how we at least
think about kind of skill learning
skills in mathematics so each circle
here is a concept in mathematics the
ones at the top those are the most basic
you know single-digit addition and
subtraction and as a student shows that
they've become proficient and then
mastery and then masters these concepts
and moves them down this tree and now
this tree goes all the way down to
college-level calculus now it's not is
it's not it's clearly not as broad as
the videos alright now you'll have
videos on art history and and and things
that go much beyond this and eventually
we do hope that this does cover as much
as as the videos do and and but the idea
here of kind of mastering a concept and
then moving on a lot of levels is common
sense it's it's the way that you would
play a video game you do you try level
one as much as you need and then you
eventually beat the boss and then you go
to level two it's the way that you you
learn a martial art you you take you you
learn the white belt skills you you
practice them you take the white belt
exam as many times as you need to and
when you pass it then you become a
yellow belt that's the way you would
learn a musical instrument but what we
always point out is this is not the way
that a traditional academic model is
structured a traditional academic model
you group students together usually by
age sometimes age and some perception of
ability and then you move that cohort
together at a set pace and what happens
in the classroom is some of the
classroom time it's a lecture then the
students go home they do homework then
the next day
they might review a little bit of the
homework then they get another lecture
and that continues for about three or
four weeks and then they have a test and
let's say that this unit is on say
entered introduction to exponents basic
exponents so you had three weeks of this
lecture homework lecture homework
lecture homework and now you have your
test and on that test let's say I get an
85 you get a 90 you get a 95 you get a
75 and even though that test identified
gaps in students knowledge even the 95
percent student that somehow didn't get
five percent of the material right even
though the test identified those gaps
and then moves on to the next concept
which could be negative exponents or
logarithms or fractional exponents
something that builds on that foundation
and to kind of see how strange that
process is imagine if we did that in
other areas of our life say home
building
so you bring the contractor in and and
and and and you say well we've been told
that we have three weeks to build the
foundation do what you can so contractor
does what they can maybe it rains maybe
some of the supplies don't show up maybe
some of the workers fell sick after
three weeks you bring the inspector in
the inspector looks around says okay the
concrete's still not quite dry there
that part's not quite up to code I'd
give it an 85 percent it's so great
that's a c-plus let's build the first
floor the same process we've got two
weeks do what you can
two weeks later 75% all right nuts build
a second floor third floor fourth floor
and then all of a sudden when the whole
thing collapses if our reaction to that
is our reaction that we typically have
in education and we might say oh we had
a horrible contractor or we needed more
inspection but the real problem and even
maybe though that was part of it but the
real problem was that you had a flawed
process you are artificially
constraining how long you had to work on
something pretty much ensuring that you
had a variable outcome and then when you
take the trouble of identifying those
gaps you just ignore them and then you
build on top of that foundation and so
what what we try to build for is a world
where instead of holding fixed when and
how long someone has to learn something
and the variable being how well they
learned at ABCD F do it the other way
around what should be fixed is that
every student should get to a very solid
foundation they should really master the
basic exponents and what's variable is
how long and when they actually have to
learn it this right over here is just a
is this a screenshot of one of the
dashboards that's being used in
classrooms now as you saw a couple
slides ago 300,000 educators are using
us in their classrooms and to different
degrees different levels of levels of
intensity but I'd like to show this one
because it highlights how you can
leverage technology to create a when I
say a more human experience a more
interactive experience in the classroom
where you could have a classroom like
this where every row there is a student
in the class every column there is one
of those concepts in mathematics the
depth of blue is the system's read on
how well that student has mastered
right now red is the system flagging
then hey this this student seems to be
struggling in some way and so the
teacher can walk in and say okay it
looks like looks like Matt's having
trouble in solid geometry and the
teacher could either do a very focused
intervention with Matt on that while
everyone else goes at their own pace or
even better gets one of the other
students it looks like this is kit right
over a year get him to tutor Matt and
then they both benefit one gets the
benefit of learning to explain things
and goes deeper the other one is
obviously getting getting getting
personalized tutoring and then there's
also the obviously the use case where if
the teacher feels comfortable that a lot
of students have have mastered a concept
it opens up class time to do a
simulation a Socratic dialogue a project
of some sort this is some data coming
out of a school in in Oakland California
it's a charter school
it's an underserved neighborhood and you
know I show this and you know I'll just
preface it with saying I don't want to
give anyone the impression that that
Khan Academy somehow some type of a
silver bullet you can kind of drop it
into a classroom and the flowers will
bloom and the butterflies will fly it's
it's a tool and like any tool it's only
going to be as effective as the context
in which it is used and but what's neat
about this classroom is that they've had
a pretty incredible set of tool users
and in particular the head teacher whose
gentleman by the name of Peter McIntosh
and they've seen dramatic this was a
school that in 2000 and I think 2010
when Peter McIntosh first joined they
were in the 20th percentile in the state
of California amongst ninth grade
algebra classes and then as you see over
the course of the last few years they've
worked their way up to the 99th
percentile in the state of California in
amongst ninth grade algebra classes and
you know what's neat about what Peter
tells us and we you know we're learning
a ton about how kind of Quetta me can be
used and what it should be by observing
classrooms like this he says you know
it's great it's you know that their math
scores improved but he actually have
used it as a as a mindset changing tool
that a lot of these students
historically came into the classroom
already thinking that there were no good
at math and also being very passive
alright teacher what should I do next
okay I don't get this they would only
engage into a problem for five seconds
before before giving up just sure that
they would never be able to do it but as
soon as they essentially turn things
around where the students were in
control it was meeting them where they
were they were allowed to build their
foundation
even if it was an algebra class if you
have trouble in decimals you're allowed
to work on decimals so that you could
build that foundation and not get
frustrated you could peer tutor each
other you realize that you're trying to
reach your goals for yourself and the
teacher is there to help you the tools
are there you're your peers are there
then it changes their mindset they take
ownership over their own learning and
what's powerful about that is that
doesn't just improve your math test
scores that improved their their scores
across all the subjects they were doing
and I think we could all appreciate
that's probably the most important life
skill the ability to self-direct
understand what your goals are and then
use resources at your disposal to to
reach them now you know I've just been
talking about schools out of the 10
million people using the site every
month about 10 percent of them are in
formal settings in schools and so we
remind ourselves that is still the bulk
are just random people maybe a minute
like like many of y'all when you were in
high school or even in college who are
trying to tap into their potential and
this next video is one we got a few
months ago that we were you know it kind
of exemplifies that
so I actually dropped out of high school
twice during my freshman year and when I
eventually came back I was put in sort
of little math and science classes
because I was so behind then I
discovered Khan Academy and I was able
to skip two years worth of math just
there using the site and I came into
school I took the exam with students who
had been enrolled in the class all year
and I was actually able to get the
highest or the second highest scores in
the class so for me Khan Academy have
really changed the trajectory of my
entire life because without it I don't
think I ever really have been inspired
to to learn and to love math it's a love
science I ended up graduating as a
valedictorian and going on to Princeton
where I'm a computer science major and
I'm absolutely passionate about learning
about computer is about math about
science and without kind of CAD me I
don't think that these things would
really matter to me the way that they do
to that so I just like to say a massive
thank you to everyone at Khan Academy
saw on the team please keep doing the
good work that you're doing because
you're really changing lives and what's
what's been neat about that is when we
found out that charlie is a computer
science major and actually opted others
to all of the computer science majors in
the room I said well you know we have
internships and so he applied and and
actually every round
everyone said strong hire strong hire
out we actually I mean it's it's unusual
to have someone get strong hires from
everyone that interviews them and
they're like who is this guy and it's
like why are you surprised
we helped educate it now but it is
exciting he actually is going to come
join us this summer so it's kind of come
full circle that he's not going to be
able to help make the tool that helped
him get that much better for the next
generation so so we're we're super super
excited this is something that y'all
might have heard about a couple weeks
ago
the College Board makers of the SAT
announced that they're coming out with a
new SAT in 2016 and what you know the
part that we play is that as part of
that they've kind of officially
recognized now that look there's this
perception that there's an equity when
it comes to the standardized test
especially like the SAT around people
who can afford expensive test prep of
you know Kaplan Krista review things
like that and so what we're very excited
about is we're partnering together the
Koz board has never done anything like
this before where they're going to share
items with us share know-how with us and
to create you know not just a free test
prep tool but really the best test prep
tool that happens to be free so not just
videos but a real interactive meets the
students where they are
allows them to work at their own pace
gives tools to coach his teachers
parents whoever they might be so that
hopefully we can we can start leveling
the playing field just a little bit more
so these are all you know one thing that
a lot of y'all might have been thinking
about is well everything I've talked
about so far is the world that most of
us live in in english-speaking world
developed world what about the rest of
the world and so all of these are our
examples these are just pictures taken
of other NGOs for the most part taking
Khan Academy sometimes offline sometimes
online and taking them to two fairly
remote places and and all of these are
pretty exciting stories but probably the
most exciting one is the one on the top
right I used to give talks like this
maybe two years ago and say you know who
knows maybe one day this will be used in
Mongolia just kind of imagining the
furthest place on the planet and and a
few months later I get an email from
Mongolia and and and it had a little
link to a video and and the video was
was made by a young woman named Zayed
the girl at the top right there and it
was kind of similar to Charlie's videos
she talked about how she likes Khan
Academy and it's helped her and she
enjoys math now and and I thought this
is neat but but I said well she must you
know I just assume she must be middle
class upper middle class she spoke
English quite well she had access to a
computer and the internet but then I
read the text of the email more closely
and it turned out that there were a
group of engineers at Cisco Systems that
were using their vacation time to go to
Asia and set up computer labs with
broadband in orphanages and so what you
see in the top right there those are
actually a Mongolian girls in an
orphanage using Khan Academy and Ziya
was one of those orphans and and that by
itself already for kind of felt like a
like a science fiction book but but
what's been even neater since then is
that Ziya has kind of like the Charlie's
story
Ziya has now she's now I think eighteen
and and so she's now contributing to
Khan Academy translating videos creating
content and she's one of our top
creators of content now in the mongolian
language we've also been it's not just
about videos the whole platform we've
been internationalizing we've launched a
completely spanish khan academy this
past fall we launched Brazilian
Portuguese a few months ago Turkish and
French are coming soon our goal is to
have all of the world's major languages
and obviously the order we're doing it
is
impact and also where we've been able to
find really good partners who could
really drive things on the ground in
those geographies and to get a sense of
what at least the video content looks
like and I want to have stress this is
much more than just the video content
but they get a sense of what the video
content looks like in other languages
I'll show this next montage those the
beat continues coming okay see she sang
sure I'm a potted block of the period
equal to the constant connectivity part
I mean not even has wasn't she on the
homonymous after us
the unit is ignoring the simple things
watch that when I get lazy so yeah these
are all more pictures of just you know
Khan Academy being used in all sorts of
parts of the world and and you know I I
tell everyone involved in Khan Academy
it's much much more than me now we have
you know 60 full-time employees we have
volunteers we have obviously you know
since since the Gates Foundation in
Google we obviously have many many other
supporters that have allowed us to scale
and and we're always looking for more
supporters as a head of a not-for-profit
I have to say that so that so we can
reach the potential and what I always
say is you know the potential here is
you know people you hear the term
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity a lot I
actually think that that under cells
where we are in history I it's actually
much closer to once in a millennium
opportunity where you have this this
thing called education this thing that
has always been the key determinant
between the haves and have-nots and but
it's always been scarce and it's always
been expensive and what I think is going
to happen it's not going to happen
overnight but I think if we kind of
collapse you know collectively work on
it over the next 10 20 30 years it is
going to get to the point where access
to
high-quality tools at minimum and
content and then things that are getting
closer and closer to world-class
education are going to become more and
more commonplace more and more
ubiquitous and more and more of a just
of an expectation and and what I like to
you know think a lot about is if if you
were to go back 400 years to Western
Europe and even then Western Europe was
one of the most educated parts of the
planet you had about a 15 20 % literacy
rate for men and about a 10% literacy
rate for women and I suspect that if you
ask say a member of the clergy who could
read back then what percentage of people
do you think are even capable of of
reading they might have said well if you
have a really good education system
maybe 40 or 50 percent are even capable
of reading and we now know that's wildly
pessimistic the answer is pretty close
to a hundred percent and so if we fast
forward to today I like to ask the same
question what what similar blinders do
we have on today if you ask if we ask
ourselves what percentage of people are
capable of understanding quantum physics
you might say maybe 1% maybe 5% maybe
maybe 20% if you have a really good
education system what percent of the
people are capable of contributing to
genetics research or or medicine you
might say oh maybe 10 20 percent if you
have a really good education system but
what if over the next 10 20 30 50 years
that gets closer to a hundred percent I
think if we do that and if we if we get
closer to making an education just just
a fundamental human right I think it'll
be a very exciting time to live thank
you
so we're going to take questions from
the audience let me point out that we're
looking for questions not I am available
for an internship and if you would
please line up at the microphones on
either side
we'll begin and and while we're waiting
Sal I have to say that what some of the
most moving parts of your talk had to do
with human potential and how we get out
of our preconceived notions about
potential through scaling up the kind of
individualized attention that you were
first able to give to your knees so
looking at the relationship between
those two and thinking about scale I'm
wondering what kind of data you collect
on your work and I mean standardized
tests maybe and whether that gets used
to iterate the scaling up you know so as
you can imagine you know we as a website
we can we're collecting everything on a
student and you know we're very careful
about privacy and that's not sure
another reason why you know I decided to
be a not-for-profit so there wouldn't be
temptations to go in one direction or
another but yeah I mean the neat thing
is we we can collect all of this really
interesting data and so that allows us
to you know actually they're probably
going to be some papers published by
some of our in-house research scientist
that have been working with some
researchers at universities on some
learning gain research that they've been
doing on there's been some research on
growth mindsets based on the work of
Carol Dweck where we were doing we were
able to do it on a scale that was a
little unprecedented where you know we
have five million exercises done every
day and and so yeah so what we're
absolutely using it to trying to
understand learning better to
personalize it for students better and
to also kind of measure the quality of
the of the experience yeah that's very
exciting and I think president Suresh
told you about the data shop the more
than a million instances of learning
that we've collected and we really do
find that that helps us
likewise build learning software that
that helps oh yeah no absolutely and I
just come and like this cosmic
partnership that gets even more excited
because it's like a it's a well defined
end point that students are trying to
reach in yeah so yeah
that's great so we're going to start
asking
for questions were lucky enough to have
Andre Hinds with us here today and he's
going to give the closing remarks
so we'll take questions and then we'll
turn it over to Andre hi thanks so much
for sharing with us today
congratulations
um I am curious what you are doing what
your platform is doing for people with
disabilities specifically I'm thinking
about how you're making your website
accessible to people with low vision and
with who are deaf yeah so so we've
started doing things there and we
haven't done everything that we can do
almost all of our videos are subtitled
and so that's wonder on the low vision
side of things we've gotten some
feedback about ways that we could make
it better we haven't you know even when
it comes to the video production some
people are getting feedback that it is
actually getting it's already close to
being useful for a lot of people who are
vision impaired but you know things like
it's not helpful if I'm saying hey up
here
you know I should I should reference
kind of what I'm doing or something like
that so I'd say we're doing it we've
started doing a little bit but we have a
lot more to do so you should a lot of
interesting stuff going on and I'm
citing the rest of the world right so
what's your data that you have on how
this is affecting minority education is
that's a big problem in the United
States and there might already gap yeah
I mean you know it's the way we've been
thinking about it right now is we we've
been matil I would say we're still at
the understanding phase of how can Khan
Academy even be used and what are the
different use cases you know based on
the the grade level the demographics of
the students where they are skill level
wise you know Oakland that Oakland unity
example was you know it's it's a it's a
underserved community and that saw some
really interesting results now it's not
like every classroom that has been using
Khan Academy sees results like that our
goal is to try to identify the really
exemplars that are moving the dial in
that way and then trying to share those
best practices and some of those best
practices are how they use Khan Academy
and some of them have nothing to do with
Khan Academy where there's some
intervention that the teachers do on a
daily basis but we also think about what
can we somehow bring that into the the
tool some how can we maybe a video of a
I don't you know is there something that
we could do to approximate that so you
know there's Oakland unity Kip has been
seeing you know once again not in all of
their classrooms but in some of the
classrooms that have been kind of really
invested in it we've been seeing some
very very powerful results but it's it's
still early it for us it's let's look at
the people using it let's see where
there's you know just unusual success
and let's try to document it and spread
those practices that's great you
mentioned that part of Khan Academy was
freeing up class time in schools how do
you think that extra class time should
be used best yeah no I you know I think
you know when human beings are in a room
the best thing for them to do is to kind
of interact with each other you know I
think there's there are some times where
a shared experience is nice whereas you
know if you're getting a talk about
something or you're watching a movie
it's nice to be in the movie hall
because it's a shared experience but if
you're if you're if you're trying to get
your heads around a nuanced problem a
fairly dense thing something that's
based on kind of your foundations going
into that you know having a lecture for
everyone where everyone is lost or bored
at different stages of it isn't the most
productive use and so yeah I would love
to see a world where it yeah it is all
about when people get together it's
either about dialogue or it's about
working on projects or it's about doing
simulations and you know it's not like
this is there's no precedent for this
this is what they've been doing the
humanities for a long time you know go
read the book and when we come we're
gonna have a Socratic dialogue about it
it happens in business schools with with
the the case method where it's all about
students talking to each other in STEM
fields it's it still tends to be more of
the large lecture hall format with with
with folks taking notes and then you
take an exam but I think stem is
probably the place where it's most
important where where people are should
be doing things they should be creating
things and you know if I were to stand
my soapbox I'll say the the next level
if more than just what happens in the
classroom what should happen in that
STEM education is much more of the
creating and the doing you know I always
it always gets me when someone says oh
I'm not into math I'm an int engineering
I'm creative and I'm like what is
engineering if not creating something
novel that has never existed before and
I think we sometimes lose
really good talent because we assess
early on you know it was happening to
Nadia in seventh grade we assess
people's ability to contribute in
mathematics I inserted
based on you know their ability to
convert units when they're in seventh
grade and you know to me that's
analogous to judging the potential of an
artist based on their ability to mix
paint when they're in seventh grade or
judging the potential of a dancer
based on their flexibility when they're
in seventh grade it's a tool those are
useful but those actually don't define
your creative potential so yeah I think
I think engineering math science should
be much more about kind of creating the
portfolios getting your core skills at
the same time and that your transcript
should be like what have you what have
you made thank you this question
thanks for coming again um my question
is about your partnership with Bank of
America and what you have in store for
the future in terms of just teaching
general public life skills such as
personal finance yeah you know the Bank
of America thing was interesting you
know back in the day obviously I was an
analyst at a hedge fund
I even you know this was early as 2007
you know I saw well there's two things
that was happening a lot of the we
started hiring some junior analysts and
these are people summa laude from
top universities and but they still were
missing some of the kind of just well
how do you understand the economy how do
you understand businesses how do you
kind of read into things and so I
started making videos for them on just
understanding financial statements and
things like that
at the same time this was like 2007
early 2008 as you all know I didn't buy
a house yet and and and it was because I
was a housing bear because I had every
you know uncle telling me oh you gotta
buy a house housing only goes up etc etc
and then I would literally like break
out nap because I was like look you know
look at like income levels since 2000
they haven't changed look at
demographics they haven't changed but
financing has changed and look at this
could you know securitization all of
their eyes would glaze over and and so I
started making videos on that and and so
and then of course when the financial
crisis hit you know even though the
hedge fund we just parked all of our
money in cash it's like we need I just
kept reading the Federal Reserve Act
over and over again to understand what
was what was going on and and and so you
can imagine that that kind of already
started to have a big following even
today one of the most popular videos is
on is on cred
default swaps on all of Khan Academy and
even I mean in those early days actually
actually in the mist it was November of
2008 I got an email I won't say from
which bank but a gentleman wrote me
thank you so much for the video on
mortgage-backed securities I now know
what I do for a living but yeah so it's
an area that's close to my heart because
it's important on so many levels it's
it's it's it's you need it to function
in you know the financial crisis is an
example where all these policy decisions
were based on accounting and most people
didn't understand accounting so people
weren't able to participate and judge
whether the right decisions were being
made or not even even a lot of our
leaders and so when you know Bank of
America reached out like a year and a
half ago say hey we want to work on
financial literacy and this and that we
were suspicious you know obviously you
were not-for-profit they're a big bank
and you know we're like we're not going
to commercialize our site we don't want
to do this and you know they said this
and it's since then they've been very
genuine about this which which has been
very impressive is that they genuinely
feel that look no we we generally want
to help people learn it's good for us if
other people get more educated on things
and we don't want it to be commercial
because that will undermine people's
confidence and what's being pretty and
we don't want editorial control that's
why we're talking to you and so yeah
that's been a really good partnership
where they've helped market us they've
helped support us they've helped and you
know and they do offer expertise if I'm
gonna make a video on you know
understanding mortgages I have access to
some of their folks now I don't get only
from them I mean the one thing I'm as
you could tell I'm pretty I want to be
independent and give things in its clear
way as possible but yeah so far so good
and but I do agree I think that is one
of the you know if I were to
re-architect
K through 12 education in my book I talk
about the current K through 12 is
especially high school is dictated by
this committee of 10 in like 1890 which
was 10 university presidents that
decided that you should learn physics
and 12th grade and chemistry and 11th
grade and calculus and all of those are
great subjects but that was 120 years
ago and I would argue that law should be
included accounting should be included
computer science should be included all
three of those are I love calculus have
maybe 300 videos on it but all of those
are more useful today that then
statistics should be included so so yeah
it's it's a it's an area that's close to
my heart so I can see why kids love
learning from you because you're you're
kind of compelling and I think that
people would sit here probably for the
next five hours happily but let's take
one more question then turn the stage
over to Andre I just want to thank you I
volunteer as an SAT tutor for multiple
years and being able to use Khan Academy
to scale and really get them really help
right now we not only have a massive
student debt about trillion dollars but
we also have new energies coming out
like Udacity that are trying to I'd say
eventually replicate a college education
do you where do you see this going over
the next five years do you think Khan
Academy is going to you know you're
gonna have a Bachelor of Arts or
Bachelor of Science from Khan Academy
soon or you know
ya know that's a good last question the
the the so on I mean on the SCT stuff
we're gonna have much better tools for
you in the next 18 months so that's very
exciting but I'm glad you are already
found it useful you know this this
costing is a fascinating question
and I write a lot about this there's a
whole chapter about it in my book so
what I'll first paint of what I think
would be the ideal College of the future
would be it's an environment that you go
to where you get all the things that we
love about college you get a camaraderie
you have a community you have clubs you
you have seminars where you can discuss
kind of very intellectual things that
could or could not be related to to the
kind of practical world to the real
world just to kind of stretch your
thinking but but you then have a chance
to spend most of your day actually going
out there and doing things whether it's
doing research or doing internships at a
firm or starting a business or whatever
working on a novel whatever it whatever
it might be and so when you when you
leave that experience whatever you want
to call it you you do have some core
skills and you do have these
intellectual experiences and you do have
all the friendships that you've created
over over these over these years but you
also have essentially four years of very
tangible experiences and a portfolio to
show and I think this is already a
reality you know when we hired Khan
Academy we are most impressed by
someone's portfolio and it could even be
unrelated to what they're doing in the
job it could be the set of their
photography that they've done and that
just shows to us that they're capable of
this kind of starting with nothing and
creating something or apps they've
written or books did whatever they've
done so so I would say that's kind of
the ideal school of the future
University of the future in my mind and
and you know there's examples that kind
of go in that direction you know
University of Waterloo in Canada
excellent engineering school there their
internship class model is kind of
flipped relative to traditional American
universities where their students spend
two thirds of their time in internships
and so what happens to those students is
their tuition is lower they get a lot of
an especially in computer science and
engineering the internships are very
high-paying and so most of these
students are leaving with savings not
debt and they and they're getting and
they're the most sought-after students
because they have all of this experience
from all the top firms
you know I think it's ironic in Silicon
Valley right now if you go to Google
Facebook Palantir you know all the
firm's Khan Academy Apple the only
interns there are from Waterloo because
everyone else is in classrooms and so
they've essentially got this monopoly on
this like really great experience that
no one else is really tapping into and
so they're getting you know they and a
lot of them get job offers as you know
two three years experience tires because
they have so much internship experience
so I think you you you have I think
that's starting to go in a very
interesting direction in terms of the
MOOCs and all of that I think they will
you know I think there's a role for for
that I think there's you know I think
for many of us who've had the who are
lucky enough to go to a school like
Carnegie Mellon where you have this
community this intellectual discourse
you're able to work with amazing
professors and researchers we say only
how can you not have that but the
reality is most most students don't get
that most students go to a commuter
college where it's a very transactional
experience they're really trying to get
a degree
they've got bills to pay they sometimes
have a family to support and so forth
and oftentimes they still don't finish
and so I think I think the MOOCs could
start to play a powerful role there
where if you're if you're if you really
just you get your core skills so that
you can signal to an employer that
you're ready I think that that should be
an option so I see the future where
there's multiple paths and people can
kind of pick it's not you must go to a
traditional four-year residential
college or else you're not going to be
able to get a white-collar job thank you
I think so